an apartment building in downtown las
vegas that was actually
missing the stairs is now completely
blocked off the apartment is right near
bruce close to cashman center
joe moeller was the first to tell you
about what happened there last week
after tenants reached out to us that
they were using
a ladder to get in and out of their
apartment
well a lot of people were wondering what
was happening with this building well as
of monday night the last tenant who
lived upstairs here
moved out today a note from the city
went up and the upstairs was
blocked off the city came they put an
orange sign the upstairs tenants moved
out and this note says this building is
substandard
they came they boarded it up that nobody
could go in there no more
gonzalo de la cruz lives downstairs he
is waiting for the building to be looked
at
once again the city said that a city
inspector has to come
and see if we're going to have to go
tuesday the stairs were also removed
sunday february 14 the car crashed into
the stairs
people were using a ladder and a chain
to get upstairs for more than a week
just last night this tenant just got out
one family was moved to a hotel after an
eight news now viewer came forward and
offered to cover the cost
the other tenant moved out monday and is
staying with family according to a
neighbor the city says the owner is
working to pull permits for the repairs
once they are done the city will be back
out to inspect it before it is used
dela cruz says he is worried about his
kids and the balcony left above his
front door i always have to worry about
them oh don't go under the balcony oh
don't go into the bathtub go play out
here play out here don't go under
i shouldn't be worrying about that the
city will be back out here to inspect
this building on
march 8. reporting in las vegas joe
mohler 8 news now
all right joe thank you and joe did
reach out to the landlord
again today to see if they know how long
repairs could take
and at this time still waiting to hear
back